you're probably aware that different
apps on your cell phone can track your
movements that location data is
commercially available along with other
personal information like your social
media profile email address and date of
birth but what the Wall Street Journal
has learned is that the government has
also bought a commercial data and is
using it for some forms of law
enforcement to components of the
Department of Homeland Security are
using this app generated marketing data
for law enforcement purposes the fact
that there are millions of cell phones
and cell phone locations in this
database makes it one of the larger
domestic surveillance efforts that we've
become aware of in recent years it
raises a lot of questions among
Americans about their privacy and what
kind of information corporations are
collecting on them and what those
corporations are doing with that
information this is how it works you get
this pop up and agree to let an app use
your location a travel app may want it
to suggest nearby hotels or airports
rideshare apps want to know where to
pick you up but often those apps are
also sharing your location with
marketers who are using it for targeted
ads research analysis and even reselling
it but what we found is that in some
cases that consumer data is being resold
to companies that buy and sell data for
the government according to people
familiar with the matter and documents
reviewed by the Wall Street Journal the
Trump administration has purchased the
database that map's the movements of
millions of cell phones in the US and is
using it for immigration and border
enforcement in 2018 data tracking
contributed to the discovery of a drug
smuggling tunnel according to people
with knowledge of the operation sources
described this one case down in Arizona
a border town called San Luiz where a
man had allegedly built a tunnel between
his property which was an abandoned KFC
restaurant and the Mexican border police
say that smugglers were using this
tunnel but the interesting thing is when
this person was arrested none of the
court records indicate that they found
this tunnel based on cell records this
data was showing cell phones moving from
one side of the borders to the other
and investigators surmise there must be
an illegal tunnel there
and began further investigations that
led to the arrest of this person in a
statement to the Wall Street Journal a
CBP spokesman said quote while CBP is
being provided access to location
information it is important to note that
such information does not include
cellular phone tower data is not
ingested in bulk and does not include
the individual uses identity the
government would not discuss details
about how it is using the data but
people familiar with some of the
government's efforts say it is used to
generate investigative leads about
possible illegal border crossings and
for detection or tracking of migrant
groups the government's location data
efforts are also described up akley in
the US Department of Homeland Security's
privacy assessment one reads quote the
goal is to utilize this data to detect
the presence of but not identify
individuals in an area which CBP has
identified as an area of interest
consistent with CBP statutory
authorities federal law and DHS policy
your average consumer looks at their
phone over a hundred and fifty times a
day the marketing technology ecosystem
has taken off in recent years marketers
create audiences based on rich device
level attributes including location
platform device type and app Opena d all
this data is built on what more than 250
million mobile consumers do in real life
every day it's big business and there
are many companies collecting all sorts
of different data anything from the
speed you are traveling to what floor
you're on to your social media profiles
some companies known as data brokers buy
different sets of this data and combine
them to create even more sophisticated
individual digital profiles while the
privacy policies of these companies say
they do not keep personal information
and explained that to them you were just
a few letters or numbers known as an ad
ID experts we spoke to say that by using
large data sets it's easy to figure out
who a phone belongs to which is one of
the reasons why this data is so valuable
to the government location data is some
of the most sensitive data that exists
Alan Butler is the general counsel at
the Electronic Privacy Information
Center a nonprofit research and advocacy
center based in DC there are a number of
different ways that a company that
obtains these data sets could identify a
person one way might be by mapping the
locations over time and because people
live in operating patterns the companies
are more concerned with you know
discrete connections they want to tie
everything together in an automated way
and the easiest way for them to do that
is by using identifiers the add ID which
is going to connect the dots all the
dots of the mobile add data but also
email addresses Facebook profiles or
Twitter profiles or other sort of app
profile data and so the more data those
companies can get about you the more
they can connect it if the government
wanted to get that kind of data from
your cell phone provider that have to
get a warrant from a judge but because
this data is for sale from marketers
they are able to buy it and
without a warrant most recently the
Supreme Court in the carpenter versus
United States case restricted the
government's ability to use a court
order to get commercial data from the
phone company which is the data about
where your phone is connecting on the
cell phone network the Supreme Court's
has not directly addressed the
purchasing of commercial data the
federal law does impose restrictions and
in the circumstances under which the
federal government can collect personal
data under the Privacy Act but that that
also can be tricky if the company never
actually stores the data in a government
database recently some companies have
taken steps to alert users about
location data this market advertising
data on smartphones is barely 10 years
old and already we're seeing that
consumers are taking more control over
their privacy in ways that could really
hurt this industry Apple in its latest
update made it so that it reminded users
how often apps are tracking them and
some industry insiders have said that
the amount of location data has
plummeted since Apple made that change
users are becoming broadly much more
aware of how their phones are tracking
them and taking steps to limit what kind
of apps have access to their location
critics argue that if companies have
this data then why shouldn't the
government also have access to it for
crime prevention I think the reaction
that law enforcement should be able to
get access to data that the companies
have access to it kind of falls into two
common traps one is that it assumes that
the company should have access to that
data too but even given the fact that
some companies have access to the data I
think law enforcement use that the data
is just a fundamentally different thing
because the government exercises the
power of the state and so we've always
had a special set of rules for the
government's collection of data and
surveillance of individuals right now
there is no comprehensive US privacy law
the European Union in 2016 passed the
general data protection regulation which
more tightly controls how European data
can be used in the u.s. there are
ongoing efforts to introduce tougher
national privacy laws in Congress
programs like this are certainly going
to fuel the call for a comprehensive
privacy law in the United States
it's that limits the way corporations
can share data bit they collect on users
California has taken some steps towards
passing some greater privacy protections
but federally there's no law that stops
or limits what corporations can do with
the data they collect on their users in
this particular market that's how it
ended up in the hands of the government